[Musique]
bonjour jean jacques gressier bonjour
vous êtes pdg de l'académie du service
vous avez été ancien directeur général
dans un grand groupe hôtelier français
bien connu pendant plusieurs années
alors pdg de l'académie du service
présentez-nous rapidement ce qu'est
l'académie du service enfin ça
sous-entend service commercial cent
cinquante ans l'ensemble des services
l'académie a pour mission de détecter
toutes les entreprises qui ont compris
aujourd'hui que cette culture de service
qui est à la fois une culture marketing
mais aussi une culture de management
devient indispensable pour la réussite
des entreprises donc nous aidons les
entreprises à réécrire l'expérience
client à réécrire l'expérience
managériale comment on travaille
ensemble pour bien servir les clients
et puis après on déploie d'été formation
pour aider les personnes à adopter de
nouveaux comportements de relation
client en management alors dans le cadre
du premier forum commerce connecté
organisé cet après midi à l'espace
aéroservices de l'aérogare du lamentin
organisé cet après midi par la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie gens-là
gressier vous animerez une conférence
intitulée la nécessité d'en chanter ses
clients une obligation qui replace
l'homme au coeur de la stratégie alors
nous y reviendrons dans quelques
instants mais il faut contextualiser un
petit peu c'est le thème de cette
conférence est tout d'abord ce constat
bien comme dans quasiment tout le reste
du vaste monde les martiniquais évoluent
dans leurs comportements d'achat en
intégrant de plus en plus l'internet et
les applications mobiles et c'est comme
ça et donc il faut faire avec pour les
divers commerçants de la place oui je
crois qu'on n'a pas le choix le digital
révolutionne tous les jours la relation
client et le monde des services donc
l'ensemble des prestataires s'ils
veulent rester compétitifs sont obligés
d'intégrer ce que cette digitalisation
de la relation client provoque dans le
métier qu'ils accomplissent mais cette
disposition qui est à la fois une
quelque chose qui a des dimensions très
technologique oc marketing replace aussi
c'est le but de le faire comprendre de
ma conférence replace l'homme au coeur
de la de la relation client
car plus on digitalis la relation client
oui ça permet même un peu paradoxal
parce qu on se dit avec avec cette
technologie c'est plutôt de la vente à
distance qui se fait
et que ça devient finalement plus
impersonnel le regardons les entreprises
qui sont nés dans le monde digital qui
ont tout de suite été très centrée sur
la satisfaction de leurs clients de
prendre des exemples de banques comme
ing direct vous comme amazon que dans le
monde du commerce
ces personnes qui ont mis en place une
stratégie de satisfaction de leurs
clients à chaque transaction
en même temps permettent à leurs clients
d'être en contact avec un être humain
dès que le besoin s'en fait sentir
donc plus on digitalise plus il faut
permettre aux clients s'ils souhaitent
un moment ou un autre à voir un rapport
humain de lui offrir et de prendre un
exemple les des analyses montrent par
exemple que les jeunes aujourd'hui dans
la banque
ils veulent pouvoir faire toutes leurs
transactions par internet
quand ils veulent tous les jours mais
90% d'entre eux aussi votre pouvoir
avoir à faire un conseiller dès qu'ils
le souhaitent
tant qu'on est bien dans un monde janka
est oui et oui justement donc il faut il
faut créer cet équilibre finalement faut
pas que ça devienne trop impersonnel non
plus quelque part les commerçants sont
comme on dirait jouer enfin sont obligés
de prendre le virage parce que sinon il
y en a qui vont rester sur le carreau
oui je pense qu'on n'a pas le choix tous
les commerces doivent aujourd'hui
intégré ce que provoque pour eux le
monde du digital est ce que mme harbour
ma réputation dans le monde d'internet
est ce qu'elle est bonne même si je suis
un petit commerçant de quartier ben je
peux avoir une réputation sur internet
si cette réputation sur internet je ne
la gère pas je ne la mets du repas sera
une répercussion sur mon chiffre
d'affaires je peux aussi imaginer quelle
que soit la taille de mon commerce que
mes clients maintenant de plus en plus
avant de se déplacer sur un point de
vente veulent avoir des informations sur
les produits et les services qui vont
leur être rendu donc oui je suis au vox
adapté s'adapter au numérique
c'est vraiment faut voir ça en termes
d'opportunités de développement
comme dans toute révolution ce qu'ils la
comprennent ils vont en faire une
opportunité
ceux qui ne vont pas la comprendre enfin
plutôt les faire mourir
on le voit bien regarder le monde du
commerce de jouets aujourd'hui il ya des
entreprises en quelques mois
keith quand disparu comme on avait eu
dans le monde de la photographie
ce qui n'avait pris le virage du digital
ans sont morts dans le monde du jouet
des entreprises nous n'ont pas survécu
et des eaux d'entreprises comme lego par
exemple qui ont su s'adapter à ce monde
digital et humains et demain font la
course en tête et ont des très bons
résultats mais mais mais ce à un coût
tout ça jean-jacques gristi alors y'en a
qui se disent bien c'est pas pour moi je
pourrais pas de façon et qui font se
dira pas autant que j'abandonne dès
maintenant parce que j'ai j'ai pas les
moyens alors est ce que ça coûte cher de
s'adapter au numérique pour faut en
permanence regardez ce que ça rapporte
je pense qu'effectivement si à chaque
fois qu'on a une innovation on regarde
ce qu'elle coûte mais qu'on n'est pas
centré sur quelle opportunité elle me
donne et nous on a quand on accompagne
nos clients on les a toujours justement
à regarder bien sûr toute adaptation un
monde nouveau coûte demande des efforts
demande aux personnes de s'adapter
demande des investissements
technologiques
oui demande d acquisition de nouvelles
compétences pour le 5 août mais ça coûte
peut-être très cher pour moi non non non
je crois qu'il faut pas pour pas avoir
cette peur là il faut je pense faire les
choses pas à pas il faut commencer
modestement mais un commerçant
aujourd'hui ne veut pas rester en dehors
de ce monde en pensant que ce monde
n'est pas le sien il doit pas à pas avec
ses moyens en mettant un peu d'argent en
regardant ce que lui rapporte cet argent
investi progresser dans ce monde dans
lequel ils rentrent peu à peu se faire
progressivement se faire par étapes et
bien sûr bien sûr si comme sais pas
c'est une révolution importante mais
faut pas la voir comme un tsunami
alors donc on en revient à ce paradoxe
parce que vous dites que bon faire ainsi
s'est créé plus de proximité entre le
commerçant et ses clients alors
développer encore un prix sur deux
regarde toutes les études aujourd'hui
les clients qu'est ce qu'ils réclament
ils veulent avoir une relation
personnalisée
ils veulent avoir une relation de plus
en plus sans effort de leur part
donc on voit bien que très vite si on
s'attache aux attentes des clients les
clients même si la relation allait
digitalisées par moments
allez aussi humanisé et quand vous
regardez les sites par exemple vous
prenez l'exemple d'une banque
le site digital vous parle à vous en
tant que personnes avec même beaucoup
d'émotion les sites digitaux maintenant
vous parle a par là un homme et vous
offre une relation très personnalisé
même si derrière il ya du big data et
des algorithmes le client lui ça c'est
pas son problème ce qu'il veut c'est
qu'on le reconnaisse en tant qu êtres
uniques et il veut être servi
vraiment comme tel alors toujours dans
cette phase de connaître mieux ses
clients
il s'agit aussi de savoir comment
identifier sa clientèle cible
ça c'est important quand on veut pas
c'est justement à ce commerce connecté
comment la dre sait donc comment lui
envoyer effectivement des informations
des promotions etc
et puis et puis comment comment la faire
revenir également cet aspect est
important
et là-dessus avec tous les messages des
fois qu'ils arrivent enfin on est inondé
par plusieurs ya pas qu un commerce
plusieurs commerçants et ce cas pas tout
de même au bout de l'exercice un risque
bon harcèlement le terme est un peu fort
mais enfin je saturation ne voulait pas
trop ziff voilà de saturation c'est sûr
ça ça fait partie aussi de la formation
de la juste parce que ça peut se
retourner finalement contre le
commerçant a oui intrusif au mal de
clients clients il veut une relation
personnalisée mais veulent la relation
quand ils la souhaitent
on voit de plus en plus d'applications
où c'est le client qui vous dit j'ai
besoin de vous contactiez et non pas le
commerçant qui contacter regardez le
bouton call ans et darty pour renaître
sur le contrat de confiance de l'après
vente
c'est le client qui appuie sur un bouton
quand il veut que darty l'appel donc ça
c'est pas intrusif donc il ya toujours
une façon de se montrer aux clients
qu'on est à son service qu'on veut faire
le fait qu'on veut le satisfaire du
premier coup ça c'est une grande attente
des clans ne pas avoir vous appelez
trois fois pour obtenir son service mais
le client c'est lui qui est le maître du
jeu c'est pas vous qui décidez de
l'appeler c'est lui qui décide quand il
a besoin de vous l'a simplement il faut
être au rendez vous il faut être au
rendez vous avec de la technologie et
avec des êtres humains qui sont tout à
fait compétent parce que l'exigence de
compétences que le client à de
l'interlocuteur avec lequel il va
discuter
même au travers de moyens digitaux ya
quand même une relation humaine qui se
crée il ya un niveau d'exigence attendu
qu'ils étaient de plus en plus élevés
merci jean jacques gressier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans sa aux
cadis donc on le rappelle vous allez
animer une conférence à 18h me
semble-t-il ce soir si je regarde à
nouveau le le programme c'est en tout
cas ce et de 15 heures à 20 heures le
forum
le premier un premier du genre feront de
connecter il faut rendre commerce
connecté de la chambre de commerce de 15
à 20 heures à l'espace aero services de
l'aéroport martinique aimé césaire et
c'est bien 18h30 donc que vous débuterez
cette conférence intitulée la nécessité
d'en chanter ses clients une obligation
qui replace l'homme au coeur de la
stratégie
bonne journée bonne conférence et puis
voilà donc on rappelle l'entrée est
gratuite 1 à ce premier forum commerce
connecté
c'est à vous mettez pas de cible merci
bertrand caruge
[Musique]